avec y en a ici qui a fait koh lanta ah
bon ouais ouais c'est doc gynéco non
ouais ouais ouais je vous donne l'info
chez vous gynéco a fait koh lanta on a
des images
regardez c'est doc gynéco lanta c'est
sûr
[Musique]
entre nature hostile soleil de plomb et
tensions au sein de la tribu les
candidats de gynéco lanta vont devoir
donner le meilleur et comme dans chaque
saison la règle est la même
à la fin il n'en restera qu'un t'es sûr
première mission pour nos aventuriers
faire le feu mais arrêtez de vous
prendre la tête ce que vous faites
j'ai un bric à les valeurs va plutôt
boire un coup
cher aventuriers une épreuve mythique de
gynéco lente à la dégustation
meriane dans la fallait bien que je
goûte
j'allais pas vous faire boire n'importe
quoi sans tester avant je suis
professionnel quand même le victoria je
peux pas le blairer
si je m'écoutais l'agent vide le coup
non mais t'énerve pas tu vas te faire du
mal allons plutôt boire un verre en voir
tu vas voir tout va bien se passer
j'ai vu comme il est bon